An understanding of the data combined with
the business issue understanding will help you as you prepare the data for your analysis,
which is the third step of the problem solving framework.
When starting an analysis,
it's a rare occasion for the data to be ready without some level of preparation.
Preparing the data generally includes one or more of the following actions,
gathering, cleansing, formatting, blending and sampling the data.
When gathering the data,
you may need to collect data from multiple sources within your organization.
The data set you are working with may have issues that you
want to resolve prior to your analysis.
This can be in the form of incorrect or missing data.
You may need to format the data by changing the way a date field appears,
renaming a field, or even rotating the data.
Similar to using a pivot table.
You may want to blend or combine your data with
other data sets to enrich it with additional variables,
similar to using the VLOOKUP lookup function in Excel.
And lastly, you may want to sample
the dataset and work with a more manageable number of records.
Referring back to our electricity example,
we identified that we may need to obtain some data from
the National Weather Service to get forecast high and low temperatures,
as well as historical temperature data.
The data we obtain may not be in a usable format,
so we may need to prepare the data for analysis by formatting,
enriching and cleansing the data.
We'll also gather data from our internal systems such as past electricity usage,
as well as any other data we may have that may prove useful to our analysis.
Maureen Wolfson has dedicated an entire course of preparing your data for analysis,
and will go into detail about the data preparation step.